they ever missed the net a few occasions flurry
made a couple of says but great Puck movement
as we've seen in the early part of this season
Johansson acrossing vanage sharp on his first
test that was Felino who was stuffed in tight
first of two back-to-back games for both these
teams against each other little have three days
off after this meet in St Paul on Thursday Marino
slides Brett scores John Marino to jper brat and
the devil's [Music] [Applause] lead first time in
the early season the devil Score first brought to
you by the New Jersey Lottery remember anything
can happen in Jersey and the Devils get it across
ball to Marino and he puts a perfect steam pass
you see how he kind of bides a little time a
little fake like he might shoot that toward
the net drops it off to Hamilton he fakes tried
to slide it to Lazar that was intercepted by
John Merill who draws a penalty coming on douge
Hamilton Joe Hansen with the extra attacker out
gets it back from capro R sprawls out again zukar
races in to find the loose Puck COV works it down
low again Hartman walking the goal line tries to
slam it side door and vanich had the door shut zuk
Carell straight away down low ta through to Eric
s and turned back Eric s sends it to the pr off
we've got 26 seconds left on the power play a lot
of possession in the offensive end for Minnesota
on this power play Hartman couldn't haul in the
pass in front now chance to get to it it's dug
out by Ryan Hartman again from the slotty rips sa
vanage check he turns away the rebound shutting
the door on Addison absolutely ran him into the
boards a couple of shifts ago it's wedged out
towards Center maroon and Smith batt Ling maroon
trying to get his stick free and he puts it in
so Pat maroon lets his stick do the talking and
scores 1-1 well this is a little peculiar he does
get in behind the devil's D but it looked like
his stick was tied up and pretty skilled play
by Pat maroon here the high flip and it bounces
past Brendan Smith so it's a little fortunate uh
for the wild but Pat maroon does a really good
job of somehow coring that Puck and getting it
to his and and chipping it past vanich who's been
terrific here in the first period you see right
there Joel Eric neck wins the faceoff for
Minnesota teams will get to know each other
really well over the next four days as
they meet again in St Paul on Thursday
night as Devils will kick off a road trip that
takes them to Minnesota St Louis Chicago and
Colorado John Marino walking the line moves it
to Kevin ball ball shot looking for deflection
it sits in front it didn't go as pilot got a
piece of it Marino's got it again Marino pulls
the trigger flurry makes the save it was blocked
up top by Felino he broke and then Marino takes
this shot yeah in behind flurry the first and
then you see the stick just gets caught up in
Johansson that's a tough break for and it leads
right to a goal on the power play Ryan Hartman
bouncing Puck to his stick and he puts it in
Minnesota leads a lot of Puck luck going for
Minnesota cuz his stick gets caught up in
Johansson's body I don't think he pulled
on it but it is a penalty and they call it
here's a shot that's I think Del deflected
up high by McLoud just a quick shot yeah
hits the shaft of his stick right to Ryan
Hartman for the easy tap in on the back end and
it's a 2-1 Minnesota lead just a good friend of
billies and doing a good job with this wild
team here's Holtz behind net feeds brat he
scores it's jper brat second of the game but we
may get a review they're already calling for it
from Minnesota but the puck has to be completely
over the line blue line and this challenge brought
to you by your local Honda dealer in my head
as soon as I saw that you almost subconsciously
hoped the Devils wouldn't score until the
puck got out of the zone so there wouldn't
be this situation and it seems like the view was
rather quick here yeah I think it's not going to
count upon review the play was deemed to be
offside therefore we have no goal some Elite Zone
enterers here in brat and both Hughes brothers
and they get it in easily this time here's Luke
Hughes moves it brat in front score Tyler tley
does it [Applause] again a power play goal tie
game so far this season The Chemistry Between
the Hughes Brothers is remarkable what a nice
little move inside the Minnesota Zone by tley and
watch Lok and Jack and they move it around up top
and then it goes down low in a beautiful pass from
jper brat excuse me right for the Tipp in in good
position Jack's going to create a similar Market
because he puts guys in good positioning this time
it was brat but in general Jack Hughes has been on
the end of a lot of those Tyler tley passes that
have led to goals you never know how a player is
going to fit in he's fit in seamlessly early paa
rips it in well he's fit in just fine as well his
third goal in two games Devil's lead 3 to2 and you
see Minnesota has a tough time handling the puck
they Bobble it on the Outlet pass and look at
Eric Halla that puck was on end and he wound up
and got all of it makes it more difficult for a
[Applause] goenda off goes well wide Addison up
top sends it left do to gello for Hartman a check
down and makes the save two saves in succession
there rebound to Erikson e rat starts it ahead
his pass trickles through the team Glides it
across Jack Hughes finds it along the wall Luke
Hughes up top down low extra pass Meer for brat
he scores this power play is arked just Beauties
Time After Time how incredible the power play
has been to start this season for the excuse me
for the Devils is again the quick Puck movement
Luke is doing a terrific job there's the OneTouch
pass to brat and he wastes no time as he this
is where last year the Devils were great when
they had a lead in the third period they were
really able to shut games down put them to bed
this year third periods have been up and down so
far so we'll see if this team can put together a
good final 20 and you know snuff any chances out
for Minnesota Mercer on the gas pedal feeds Curtis
Lazar he rolls past Addison takes a shoulder but
the puck comes behind net for a hall of fights
for it against his former team a backhanded shot
comes the doorstep and Mercer's denied and Eric
H have also scored for New Jersey Marino moves
away changing direction against Johansson brat
oh looking for the hatrick ball fanned on the
rebound good save by Flur on brat really nice
setup for Marino and folino with a cross ice pass
comes back to Felino again glid it across maroon
at the do he scored the first goal today for
Minnesota on the wrap centers in front score
Jake Middleton makes it a one goal game off the
feed for Maroon here we go 443 left and Devils
plenty of opportunities to take a three-goal lead
makes this a hockey game and it almost looks like
and we saw it here in New Jersey that maroon is
in slow motion but he's so big and he's able to
protect that puck comes around the n and Jake
Middleton nobody's able to get to his stick
and somehow maroon finds him with 12 seconds
to go one final surge for Minnesota Erikson e
into the Zone Lazar trying to knock it shots
denied by Van final 3 seconds Lazar into the
corner and there's the buer vanich comes up huge
on capriso and the Devils hang on for a 43 win